okay all right four people joining a
live stream this is a continuing
discussion about incremental language
development for wolf language and we
have a variety of topics today okay
ascending and descending order sorting
for sort by buck today yeah for this
discussion hello hi my name is applied
to each element of the list okay alright
what is the issue here is the issue some
kind of correspondence with database
sorting or what No okay so we talked
about this maybe you here and something
ago and the point is that well database
is established precedent but I think
this is useful in general for the
language so sometimes you want to sort
by different functions having a
tie-break but the functions are for
example not all numerical one of them
could be you know I sort by you know we
remove the first two characters of the
string and then you sort by that but you
want to reverse order I say I see I see
so it's a it's a sort by I mean in other
words if if it was just numbers you just
put a minus sign in front
exactly and that's something what you do
but so sorry there are two related
important things here one is that we
have recently introduced reverse reverse
sort and reverse or by and the second is
the third element of sort by it takes
and Orleans order dating function okay
so why isn't the ordering function just
a third element um and we do have a
notion of given an ordering function say
numerical sort or alphabet sorry
numerical order or alphabetic order how
to reverse it
and I think that's what I understand so
in it
the pension Peter uh-oh I see that's the
ordering so that would be so if that was
if that third element there was a
reversed so he'd say sort by list F and
then some kind of reverse sir what would
that reverser be is that reverse that's
what you're proposing reverse order a
well I think Carlo is proposing to
reverse the function itself which I
don't really understand I would reverse
the ordering function okay so the reason
why I am proposing that is that I mean
at least in the cases in the case for
databases we have already used the third
argument for for for limiting the result
so I want the first two or the last now
the the problem with with with the
ordering function is that the ordering
function don't really apply to SQL you
have only one lexicographic order you
can have collation I don't care what
happens with us yeah but we're gonna
figure out that bridge later but the
point is that what do you do if there's
no what you want is just lexicographic
order but reversed like you didn't
really specify alphabetical marital or
whatever I didn't understand that
comment I mean to my mind
look we have the notion of if I say sort
by and I've got you know well here so I
by this comma and then I say identity
and then what is this ordering function
is it something where I can say - order
of hash hash what will that do
yeah it'll do that right yes
whereas if I say Plus that then it'll be
in in in that order right okay so this -
order thing or alternatively I could
write this could I not as is this
correct that's a fault yeah no I
understand that but I mean in other
words so another way to do this if we
had a function reverse order that was
simply the same as order but with
reverse signs does this work for a list
of functions in the second and third
argument as well well it's not
documented not yet so right now we only
have one single alternate function come
on - all day because that's that's the
case I mean begins where you just
reverse the common order that's the
reverse sort so it's not terribly
interesting the point is that you might
want one in one direction one in the
other that's where it becomes
interesting and that's where I also
think it's kinda becomes kind of
ungainly to keep track of you know five
different functions in the second and
find the second in the third argument so
this is a discussion we had when adding
this third element we are planning to
add a list in the third element and then
have a perspective ordering functions
the alternative idea was to use a lists
of rules in the second argument but I
think it was Jeremy who pointed out that
that syntax is already meaningful now
what could be nothing but in principle
we can put anything we want in the
second argument so why not rules if
somebody wanted to do that for some
reason because rules well okay fine I
mean
that seems obscure since the
mid-atlantic to be fair I mean one can
document an exception to that rule yeah
hey Dan could you screen capture that
that um that autocomplete which is
absolutely absurd yes and find out why
they reversed by orthogonal spline
wavelet occurs in third place there yes
okay that's one of those things about
which we should just be silent here
anyway never mind okay go ahead um so I
think there are two important thing two
different things here one is whether
these additional mark we need should be
in the ordering function or the function
itself which I'm more or less convinced
it should be in the orient function and
then how to represent it whether we need
a third argument or the second argument
okay so what does this semantically mean
what would this mean what would this
return you know if I apply that function
to something what on earth does it
return I mean let's say that that um you
know there's an alphabetic okay so
alphabetic order where do I put that if
I want to sort by alphabetically what do
I do it would have to go into the third
argument of sort by or the second of
soft I say it's the comparison function
exactly I just wanted to add another
thing to this thing that Jeremy pointed
out and it's that lexicographic ordering
birds into symbolic wrappers so if you
if you have something that doesn't have
a evaluation semantics in the second
argument of sort by you getting exactly
the same order so if you do sort by F is
the same as doing sort by Ln C if F
doesn't have the initials mm-hmm do you
agree that F in the second argument is a
function producing strings and then
alphabetical order is the comparison
function that goes in the third now yeah
I understand that what I'm saying
is an argument for having a rule it's
it's much simpler to type and it's much
simpler to keep track off because in
general I mean at least what we've seen
is that in most new skills you have say
for ordering functions it's 1 Kings when
you need to specify your reverse order
and so the fact that you have to write
basically a constant array of order and
then put in the middle reverse order to
achieve something that could be actually
much shorter syntax because integrating
could be used but who doesn't have any
valuation semantics
oh I understand I understand okay so
this question about whether it's okay so
reverse order in this form is just a
negation of the order function so that's
fairly straightforward so what you're
proposing a potential proposal would be
that the form that this is the usual
form
this is theme and that that that is an
alternate form and that if there are
multiple things with tiebreakers you say
you know F reverse order G order or just
G this point yeah that could just be G
yeah I mean that's kind of nice I think
that's that's um um now there is another
advantage that is that it can be used in
the operator form sort by that is a very
good advantage and the other thing we
could do is keep the third argument and
document it has the default so if you
don't put a rule then you get what you
had in the third argument that's also
very reasonable yeah right so that that
then is an illusion of everything is
reversed
you just put it as a third argument now
I don't think this is enough because
imagine that we are dealing with
numerical order and we are saying
there's another form that we could have
here I could also have FG air over soda
go on what we're going to say about
numerical sorted yes so here we have
order canonical order and reverse
canonical order but imagine that we are
dealing with numerical order and is it's
reversed yeah the direction and another
thing is the order or comparison
function right so some well yeah we need
an order reversed wrapper around order
in functions which technically is -
because reverse order functions return +
or - or - or false order in functions of
ordered right yes but it's documented to
be accepted as for as well so order
function or the new functions can return
either true or false or +1 0 minus 1 so
ordered queue returns true or false yes
and it can be placed in the second
argument of sort let's let's come back
that comes back to my original proposal
of having something that maybe it should
be so if we had a function that is like
reverse order or whatever that when
wrapped around so I I don't know what
happens if if what comes first - true or
- false if if that doesn't reverse the
order then we want something that is
lexicographically reversing the order
I'm confused by all of this I mean first
of all it certainly can't be called
reverse order because reverse order
would be no so what the heck is this
thing okay so what it's doing what is
this doing I mean I understand what this
system what this reverse order thing is
doing
but what you're saying is yes so what
I'm saying is we need a function let's
call it reversed order or or or they're
reversed that takes an ordering function
and then two arguments and then it's
like reverse seeing those two arguments
so it'll be a very simple definition it
would be first okay so we're still
saying that this will return is
effectively - that has the it will be
order of BA
yeah so so if you change order by P we
typically call this ordering functions P
so it will be reversed of P of a be
colon equals P of BA
exactly so this is like I mean it
doesn't look to be just for ordering
functions we grab this work for any bulk
functions there yeah
swaps like not just swaps the changes
the first to the last and so on in a
sense is discovery of T is it it is but
but of course it doesn't read well in
the ordering world that will be so
freakin obscure right but now in the
case of curry of ABC oops
that's just gonna be that that just
peels off one piece so the general case
we went that we would have to use
permutations tariff be three two one
yeah I understand but but reversed you
know could perfectly well go to P of CBA
maybe argument reverse that's hopeless
they think about what the code is going
to read like
um the other option is to have like what
I was proposing is like 12 something
which is kind of a universal - were
lexicographic order no it doesn't have a
nose until you into anything it's some
kind of weird thing which is gonna hang
out there as kind of a you know an
indicator it's not it's much cleaner if
it can actually evaluate because that
way you can write code I mean if you if
you every worst of the F of a and that
means reverse so that would be I mean
what are you talking about I mean look
look this okay if we did it this way
then what this would look like is
reversed of F comma G no exactly no I
mean this is what I was proposing and
not it's not what it is exactly right no
because Athens not a comparison function
f is a by function so if you want to
write through this that way then you
have to say that's reverse of F close
square bracket a open square bracket is
reversed of F of a and the true list has
a special meaning lexicographic order
but so what the students should write
here is s goes to reverse order
reversal we're not having two things no
no no but I'm saying what we discussed
at the end of your notebook is having
here F our row reversed bracket order
and that works sorry f RL what F ro
reversed bracket order bracket exactly
and then comma G goes to order so that
that would work because in another way
you can have my vetcorps there make a
lot of any order there inside us
interesting it's kind of interesting use
of functional programming constructs
I mean curly we can have an illusion
that reverse order is the same as
reverse to order if we care about that
yep if we want into you smooth you now
is reversed the right name I mean it's
clearly something like reversed um
but is that exactly the right ending I
think if we want to use it in other
places reversed sounds good well but
let's just walk through what it would
actually say so it would say you know
reversed of F represents a version of F
which takes its arguments in reverse
order okay where am i storing this LD
material I'm Devin I could give you the
cop-out answer which is in the
miscellaneous folder I'm unsure of
another place to store it all right we
perhaps should have a section here
called ILD what do you think yes oh the
yeah yeah I was thinking something like
LD or like functional programming or
something well have we had enough stuff
for functional programming not sure what
else is in the miscellaneous older well
I guess it's right there yeah let's put
this here so so reversed one okay
you
oh yeah again part of speech question
it's not the F that is reversed
okay so other possible things will be
reversed soul of f reverse sing
[Music]
you
we'll help other people's help when we
were designing Kaveri we had two
functions for some time and one of them
was called Kaveri swap I think that was
doing precisely this and Roman wrote to
me recently saying that the proper name
too for this in the computer science
community is curry see Carol
curry capital see this operation
yes dissipation of of reversing the
arguments commit us know tough luck yeah
I mean I didn't know that what I'm sorry
i'm i'm i consider myself respectably
educated here i find it too obscure
there okay Sandra our live stream has
just written a piece of code which I'm
going to reproduce here and then okay
that's a different line okay that's the
definition of oops
that's the definition of reversed okay
now yeah right
agreed that's what it does actually you
don't need the sequence just that Piatt
at yeah I appeared heard that um yeah I
mean what's interesting about this is
that we could advertise reversed as an
alternative to curry as a less obscure
name for the operation of you know sort
of initial curry so to speak sir I'm
saying yep we might have designed curry
differently if we knew we were having
this because we could have then done
curry as the forward curry so to speak
rather than the reverse in curry I think
that's disastrous and Karissa still
experimental
is it yes well then let's let's look
back at what we did for curry because it
could be that reversed becomes this
operation of swapping I don't know if
that's a good idea because it may be the
curry has other that's okay that's a
separate thing to discuss it all right
it doesn't generalize to more arguments
right now what reversed here can be
literally all the arguments right and we
could take have reversed take a second
argument which is some kind of take spec
or a permutation to say exactly what to
reverse I don't know if that's useful I
mean it seems like maybe it's overkill I
think we would have curry in general to
do that fine all right well this sounds
good to me
this is kind of cool actually so then
then this is the the form that we would
do four sort by and four sort it would
just say sort of list kama reversed of
order correct okay so just to be clear
what happens to what we have for for
shorter than T class right now is
function or property goes to a string
that's ascending or descending but the
order idea doesn't doesn't really apply
for what what are we talking about now
sort identity class we could support
ascending and descending as equivalent
order reverse order I agree as strings
yeah that's what I think we should do
okay
so this is the way it is I think so I
mean we could support reverse of order
and and reversed of order and order also
in sorted entity class we wanted to but
but primarily there are only those two
possibilities yeah but I I think it's
kind of interest because might give
people the idea that
the order that they're gonna get in SQL
is the same as lexicographic order in
Mathematica which is not the case what
is the order I mean might even be back
independent it depends on if if you have
students it depends on how they are
declared in the schema because if it's
alphabetical then you need to define a
collation so it's it's very complicated
I don't think we want to go in
documenting the quirks of different
backends okay
you get what you get in many case it's
gonna be reasonable but not the surplus
so which orders do you support here just
ascending in descent no orders none we
just support ascending and descending
and then whatever the backend deems
appropriate for for that for that column
yeah Sandra on our live stream is
commenting that reverse sounds like a
very general thing but I think it's the
only name that isn't going to be obscure
um I mean yeah my only question is
whether the ending of that word could be
anything different
did you get what I'm saying yes I mean
like reversal once well I just typed
here yes oh my eyes aren't quite like
the fact it that it is a single word
because I think it's very good that it's
a single word it has to be reversed
something or other because reverse
function is too long yeah yeah I think
go ahead why look what all right so it's
reverse of curry okay good um I'm
skip Carey see along with them you know
some random Combinator that that
somebody put in I mean this is this is a
you know this could be thought of as a
combination kind and in fact this might
even be is this the S Combinator
anyway but we're not gonna call it to
Combinator s that would be just
unbelievably obscure okay this sounds
good to me let's go ahead with this to
GUI decide on tiebreaking sorry for you
guys think about that okay okay all
right on to the next item details of
integer can I go away
yep thank you very much all right all
right so this goes to discuss this okay
and what what do we get I mean we've
also now got Babylonian and things right
I mean we've also got within the
function repository and I don't know if
you've seen this this is some for this
other project um for our Museum of math
project we are getting
let's see if I can pull it up
you
um
ancient number representations no I was
looking for the interactive thing oh
it's in your Dropbox
yeah I'm looking at interactive number
systems and then what where is it which
one of these is it the last one has
everything okay
all right so this is all kinds of oh my
gosh we've added all kinds of crazy
things we're gonna have every void in it
well where's it where's the interactive
version oh is that it
yes so have to evaluate this
you
well that's not going very far is it
okay well anyway so so you see all these
different things right which include
let's see
you
ancient numerals who say as the function
poetry ancient number representation oh
this is such a bad search thing we gotta
fix that could you report that is yet
another such problem okay
you
a splish bit separate notebook
okay so here okay so is this an integer
name or is this not an integer name the
thing we're about to get out of it
that'll and load what maybe I need to
restrain labelled is running still
what's that the notebook in the
background still running
you
okay well hopefully this will come
through in a minute um anyway so there
are many things here now of course okay
unfortunate I don't think that's a
string because it's got I mean it's
certainly it's a graphic here but even
in Unicode right this is gonna be a
bunch of things you know all on top of
each other and so on
right well the problem right with this
very old ancient more existence that
prolly they don't have any character to
represent them no no I mean well I mean
I don't know in Unicode whether I mean
this isn't base 60 so I can't really
read this number off immediately but I
don't know whether this thing here is a
glyph or whether this is nine glyphs to
go what I'm saying yeah that will make
you how do you think it's present let's
ring right but even in the Roman numeral
system okay so we've got the following
issue if I say Roman numeral of um you
know some big number okay even bigger
number
right there's that bar thing that starts
happening
okay
on a making sense so you know what is
interested name what is its contract for
what it returns I don't think it always
has to return a string that's it
so there is a difference we have into
our name and we have interesting that's
right and the idea is that interesting
returns and marek representation given
returns of water in a numeric system
returns a string as they be of interest
Rheem vs. Intel name which returns the
food works in a given language so
probably this and just string is closer
to what's happening here but I mean if I
say it's just rain
of this number comma Roman
what the heck is that what is because
that's actually a string boxes oh yeah
that's all the same and also we have
Roman variant you can try that which
uses the unicode's for these larger
Roman values within bigger string
what what's that so those are actually
the unica quotes for four large common
values
what do you mean they're the Unicode
code well they don't kind of thing like
that yes it's the committed that he that
exists existed so you're claiming this
is what the what they used for that is
that what you're saying
yes that was a variant you said by
Romulus himself no doubt
I don't know where this comes from I
mean the maybe it was taught by the wolf
never mind
I'm just being ridiculous okay
well I never heard of that I never knew
that I never knew that existed
well that's cool
all right I had no idea what is that
thing I mean do we is that a um c-could
you try something even larger to see how
much Disco's yeah I mean this is pretty
weird what this says on the that's
really weird okay let's go larger let's
watch the thing blow itself up okay
that's an amusing problem it reminds me
of transfinite numbers where you're
where you're naming you know whereas you
go to the limit you know am i go to the
Omega to the Omega whatever you get to
epsilon 0 then you limit those and you
you always have to keep generating new
names and so the so this point when you
run out of names it's because the
Unicode characters are missing never
mind
I'm sorry I'm just having my little
human moment here for um the UM I get a
link of right oh let me see sander is
sending it this is probably gonna be
horrifying oh yeah yeah well that should
be fixed
right um okay but anyway so basically
you're saying up to up to a hundred
thousand there are characters so I don't
know if make a system that doesn't need
string representation should be included
and everything on different functional
generic graphics these makes yeah I mean
look by the time I doing this we're also
I mean this is a this is for now a
function repositories kind of thing I
think we need to understand I mean
canary form is not on plane zero in
Unicode right so I don't know what the
glyph system is for that so we need to
look that up
and clearly we can do this with boxes
but it's pretty grotesque I mean with
string embedded boxes
sorry looking at the quartet Eric has it
looks like his drawing graphics like
lines here's yeah yes because that's we
quiz we can't we can't render that
unicode in all platforms yet we will be
able to soon we can render it on some
platforms because it's a minoo it's just
complicated to deal with that I I don't
know where um let's see if we say
I don't know I just don't remember that
there are code points for these things
um yeah yeah it seems they have had it
all that clinical before yeah yeah habit
but I'm asking you the question have
they had it this is this is totally
freaking weird okay so Acadian right the
Akkadian Empire all good okay cool that
we have that but look at this why is
there periodic interest in the Akkadian
Empire
honey that's related to academic
semesters for school it has to be it has
to be that there are you know people
studying it at a particular stage or
maybe there's some country maybe in the
French school system where everything is
mapped to the day they study the
Acadians on a particular day of the year
um
we have an irrelevant question on the on
the live stream from ethan asking when
are we gonna have meetings on net train
I have no idea but I know those uh I
guess we're not live-streaming some of
those though we do have machine learning
meetings and we could that okay the
responding to our audience
Sushma maybe you could find out whether
they agendas are interesting enough to
live stream for some of the upcoming
machine learning meetings yep um
sometimes those are really are really
not exciting um no they're exciting but
in different ways they're mostly about
resource and terminal resource
allocation um okay so what what is the
question here
well the question was absolutely
different what about in Taylor named the
fact that there was a thing about
changing the default value for the
second argument is the its words which
changed from below 1000 it's the full
name but after 1000 it becomes numbers
3d8
blocks and then only thousand million
billion and setting I'm sorry what is
the preparing right now if I say enter
your name of something like this I get
that
right right so if it was some kind
somehow inconsistent with the low
numbers
no that's the automatic setting look if
I want this
I think this is actually pretty good
behavior and I think that you know
having something where there's a
crossover from one to the other is
reasonable what what are the
hey what's wrong with this I don't
understand what's wrong with this what's
wrong with this explain the problem I
don't see a problem what's right he
wanted words to be default I don't care
it's not no it's not happening we've
this is a non experimental function we
chose it well it's it's done the other
inconstancy we still have which is more
issues that for other languages in fall
this very words always well then what's
wrong because we don't have yet maybe
it's words okay then we should get that
that's okay and that's no good
right but I mean clearly we can fix that
by and you probably know if that's
correct I do not um but yeah okay fine
so I mean we got to fix that also the
fact that it you know blows the top off
when it's too big a number for something
like Spanish I limit which brings that's
right
that's something we need Lewiston okay
fine
I mean seems like a good intern project
for somebody or possibly possibly our
data curation team
to go through and essentially make the
template for that because I think
they're all going to be since in the
modern world actually um modern well I
think everybody's decimal for these
these kinds of numbers um and we don't
have to have for the for the weird
ordinal cases and things we're not going
to have a you know we're not gonna have
the the quadrillion the three
quadrillion 200 and blah blah blah blah
no you don't care about that see what
I'm saying
right that's not even supported yet for
English that's right
right okay but the okay so that's thing
number one thing number two is the
ancient number systems okay and what
we're gonna do with those um and I don't
even know okay so for example those
Latin work right now
you know that's not does not work I
think we should get that to work it's
rather straightforward and it's
something the people yeah let's get that
to work I mean it's a simple algorithm
make sense and it's educationally
relevant
and I guess what do we do with the if we
say integer name
oh I see we just have language here
whereas integer string has different
kinds of yeah has different kinds of
integers that's right as opposed to
entered your name which has to have a
human language make sense right so they
do different names that it's a full name
in some language variants right
according on fine I mean it could be the
case I don't really know whether you
know in Akkadian maybe the name of the
number was the same as the as the
writing of the number itself I have no
idea
that's about our case we already have
some Oriental languages so in Chinese is
the same okay
okay fine okay okay
could it be that the ancien case is more
like a form it's and then we allow
ourselves to use any type of typesetting
like base for my thinking of base form
if you say that well we say integer it's
pretty weird to have three of these and
just string integer name and reform but
not necessarily integer it's some sort
of mean were they able to handle
fractions or something yes often and
weird ways well are you seriously
imagining I mean we could imagine this
is pretty wild that number form somehow
has that's really wild once let's say
unsigned number form was the second
argument
was ancient more generic numerical form
age so we could support also raw magnet
sitter
well the other thing which we don't
support right now is the Unicode symbols
for like 3/4 right there is a distinct
Unicode symbol for 3/4 but we don't use
it by making sense all right let's
put this on the agenda again um I'm
trying to think here whether um I mean
in integer string we kind of cooked our
goose on that one by calling it string
but then that's actually what we wanted
there because that is typically a string
hmm all right to be continued I mean I
think once I mean Eric is putting those
ancient number things into the function
repository let's see what pathologies
there are in those before we start
worrying more about this make sense yeah
okay I had no idea that there was that
simple foot foot 10,000 fascinating okay
question about fold while list the
termination of fold while list okay
didn't we discuss this last time we
started discussing it but you said these
require more thought here we have found
important presence from nest while in
and what we are not sure whether it's
good enough so the problem is I show I
found I was going through my archive
materials I found a note from 1989 which
listed take while as a function to
implement so I'm glad we finally did it
okay so what's the issue here the issues
that nest while and the current
implementation of fault while show the
last failure so the first failure as
last element while for example take
while only take takes valid elements and
while itself does what
well while doesn't return a result and
it it doesn't do that the the first case
time that the test fails it's out of
there exactly and it doesn't do anything
later yeah its repeat until we'll do the
first failure case what depends on how
the while is set up some languages have
a do-while so you do action while
whatever and others its while whatever
do and so then the one you have have the
first failure case and the other you
don't
okay okay so wait a minute so the main
issue here is that we are inconsistent
between nest while and nest while and
take while right that's the issue take
while does not include the failing case
nest while does include the failing case
and the reason for that is that nest
while lists it doesn't include the
failing case then it has to have
essentially a negative length list if it
failed in the first instance is that
right or am I am i confused there when
it just be an empty list now I'm
wondering why it isn't an empty list
what does nest while return if it fails
in the first in the failure okay in the
first case makes I think it returns an
error condition yeah she could um
background noise guys did we get nest
well wrong my gosh it's been with us
since 1999 until the results is no
longer positive so
you
nest while
that's even and then return the first
failing case
I mean what's really kind of annoying is
that there's no way to monkey it with
with it with its later arguments to
determine but there's a bunch of weird
like seashell background noise can we
try to get rid of that please huh
disappeared amazing um okay so the issue
right now is
fourfold while
okay I don't understand what happens
things like map while then we could
imagine a map while as well couldn't we
yes I think so
if we mad over the take while I guess
no because it leaves it would leave
later elements on
unmapped so to speak so I'm saying
I see I see yeah
you
so I mean if I said map while
f
um
I don't even know whether it's a
precondition or a post condition see
what I'm saying
that so then that would return F of 1 F
of 2 boring boring boring F of 5 and
then probably 6 7 8 9 10
all right although I don't completely
know whether it's it's I mean that would
not return that would be crazy to have
an F of 6 in there yes yes
so this would be like to take one now an
alternative would be a headdress wrapper
type thing around the F that says and
I'm just wondering whether there's a
head dressing approach to doing take you
know some of these other wiles as well
because what we could imagine is a
headdress that basically says
well it's ultimately if hash is less
than six amperes and F otherwise
identity
you
I think you want the high shots what'll
I do wrong here I think you do need a
there hushed in sight
what do you mean I don't need this
yes oh you're right but then I need yeah
okay that's wrong this is wrong this is
Ronnie they're right that's correct now
um what is that thing there
I mean it's like a conditional
expression type thing
you
you
hmm
well anyway okay but back to the fold
Wilde case I'm a little concerned that
we we we might you know while everything
although clearly nest while okay so nest
while is clearly applied to the result
map while in this formulation is being
applied to the input not to the result
making sense yes but in that sense it's
like take one potato well has no result
other than the actual elements
themselves yes
all right so back to this I mean um
okay what is the question here my
impression is that we cannot change full
while so sorry this one it has been
there for too long so the question is
whether we respect the president or we
move away from it yeah it's it's the UM
the strongest point of the current
president is that we can return always
something because even if the seed
element is wrong already wasting still
can't return it is --fold wha
useful with this returning the first
failure case I mean clearly for well
list you could just say most of it if
you didn't want the failure case
but fold while itself may be kind of
useless I don't know what's it what are
some good examples of fold while let's
come up with a few examples of fold
while okay and then let's Danny you were
creating background noise by moving my
mouse I don't think so okay all right
fine then it isn't you okay well it was
now went on mute um all right so I think
that's the place to go next
is let's generate some examples okay
let's see how disastrous it is for fold
while to return the failing element
failing case make sense or we may
discover that's actually what we wanted
to return okay okay I mean I think fold
while
so you know an example of a the use of
it would be some kind of transducing um
you know one of those mealy machine
thingies um what are they called
you know finite automata my you're
reading symbols in and you're walking
around the finite automaton okay and
then what this is saying is you reach
you know let's say you're trying to do
pausing you reach a thing that doesn't
work do you want the last thing that
worked
I kind of think in that case you want
the thing that doesn't work I think
that's a case where you want the the the
symbol that was off the end of the parse
so that's it that's an argument for
returning the first failing case let's
let's do some examples of this fair yep
okay let's try and do one more of one or
two more of these so can we look at
their operator forms part
that's here so the previous parting
enfold we were comparing the syntax of
the operative form of fold with the
baritone form of fall while so we just
want to check with you that you are okay
with this because in fold we introduce
these two arcs form yes
you
well here will be a three argument form
right the minimum case is that is that
second thing you're giving there three
argument form with the list and the
criterion exactly yeah
so the main question is whether we want
that to that case I would think we do
but if we go down to two arguments no
two wouldn't be possible to fall at one
well it is and the operator form there
exactly yes
because in general operator forms are
most useful when when they take a single
argument in the second pair of brackets
yeah I understand which is which is why
we want the three argument form and fold
while which goes to a two plus one
argument form in the operator case okay
it sounds good to me
so here we have two corner cases and we
just want to check with you that you are
okay in this case I'm I'm very much
convinced I'm suggesting their right
thing that it should be F of no
arguments
exactly rather than an empty list okay
so there's one layer of list here
there's two layers of list yeah there
should be zero layers of Lists in that
case I agree
in armaments yep yeah and and we have
the sense already of this behavior oh
that's interesting constructive f yeah
makes sense okay
you
okay so what are you suggesting that the
array of f operator form should it's
just literally the one the first
argument and then the second argument
ends up being the the payload of the
operator form correct like map and map
thread and all there
apply something from the left functions
seems okay to me
okay so we'll implement those two
changes yep
what about the case of array of F of two
arguments what do you mean um this this
form here
arrey of air
two two comma three should work right
that's the operator form of array of F
cover two two comma three it's a minor
corner case but I think we might as well
support it okay Danny do we do that in
with other functions supporting two
arguments in the second pair of brackets
in the second pair of brackets I believe
if we do hmm
I'm fairly sure I think some of them I
don't know we may even allow options
well I'm not positive one that was bad
Sandro and I live stream is pointing to
drop while
Oh
obits in the function repository
right and drop while accepted what does
it do what is it what it what is it does
it have so when it take while takes
nothing that violates the criterion
right yes
what does drop while do
I think it would drop all that violet
all that Oh basically right leaving only
those things which are leaving or
leaving the first thing that doesn't
obey the criterion
so sorry so this is some bit more
difficult discussion so the ideas that
transpose with a vector has always
failed
however it might be made to work by
supporting this default the fact that
the least one freedom so vector the idea
is that people so you're saying that
transpose of ABC should return ABC yep
because then that would help the people
who write these combinations of
transpose vectors dot matrix dot vector
I see
seems reasonable to me I mean you're
saying that transpose the definition of
transpose is that it interchanges so
it's doing a permutation on the tensor
indices right right okay so in this
particular case the only you know there
is only one tenser index so the only
thing it could possibly do is leave it
the same exactly yeah
so the the documentation could not say
now by default the transpose is the
first two levels it would have to say
something a slightly more complicated
but it'll become more useful I think
it's fine
I mean we in terms of you know it could
say transpose the first two levels of a
list that is of depth two or more and
then it could break out the other case
right and yeah so I've asked other
people like a rough nap and Roger and
they are okay with this stage I think
it's a good change I think for at least
for typesetting some operations it's
going to become useful right okay
position Lord
yeah so Danny can you explain him sorry
I'm okay so the specs that I've seen for
this I did not leave me clear on what it
is that we're supposed to implement okay
I don't think we're gonna get to that
we've only got four minutes here so I
mean let's let's cover this another time
okay my live stream is asking how do we
represent column vectors we don't need
to that is the whole beauty of the way
that we do our tensor manipulation um go
on please because we don't need to
distinguish love actors from vectors at
this stage we need to distinguish Co
vectors only what am i doing well Jose
you can help say what the cutter when
when we have to do that right so the
idea of the traditional idea of using
vectors and conductors is just a
notational device to to to explain how
to do these multiplications the dot
multiplication but then it's also used
sometimes to express the true difference
between vectors and cofactors in physics
shows up in in in well what it shows up
any in any situation in which you have a
metric which is not one one one right
and at that company should happen the
momentum wait a minute that's not
correct the the momentum
I'm confused there yes so for example
imagine all these lagrangians that have
P a X a so P well we would call P dot X
yeah right so in order to support that
with any type of coordinates curved
coordinates all are etc you have to make
the XS or the X dot always factors and
the P are covectors how are we dealing
with that and curved coordinate systems
we we are not right now so when we have
coordinates our data we are using or
frames that are also normalized even if
they come from polar coordinates so it
precisely to avoid this distinction of
vectors and conductors whalemen so so
isn't there a theta hat than our hat in
polar coordinates well one of them those
happen to be orthogonal but but is that
always the case well there are the
so-called coordinate vector basis
vectors coordinate basis vectors and
those are not all for normal in in polar
coordinates for example they are not
normal I mean the the coordinates theta
vector has length R as you get further
further away it's longer and longer and
that's why you normalize them and then
you have orphan normal vectors actually
so that's why the metric in the
coordinate metric in empower coordinates
has the diagonal one R squared meaning
the theta coordinated vector becomes
longer and longer with r IC so by having
also normal basis vectors we avoid the
problem we avoid the need to have Co
vectors
exactly but if you want to do
computations with with coordinated
vectors in which you don't also
normalize then the metric is non-trivial
and it is super important to keep track
of whether you're half vectors or
collectors whether what has happened in
this my last question here what has
happened to the effort the the oleg
effort the the long-awaited
oleg effort to get us more coordinate
systems and so on well I think it's just
in back partner he collected many of
them and we have here the fundamental I
think 11 coordinate systems with this
ortho normalization idea that can work
for any coordinate system is that true
it can work yes for any of them but
these special coordinate systems have
special properties like the laplacian is
particularly separable and things of
that so not
all coordinate system would have as nice
properties as these release this okay my
one physics minute this orthonormal
basis thingy is that doable in all the
random coordinate system to Donald's
everyday or is the other cases where
there's singularities in those no
orthonormal a safe well let's see so in
in gravity we have something similar
which is like a so-called VLBI
you know the this orthonormal yes we use
the german war they feel a brine fear by
its act sorry I forgot exactly so we can
always select another explanation of
what fear binds all right that's a
better explanation than I knew before
okay fine yeah but there is still some
hidden I mean you are moving the
complexity of the curvature somewhere so
all these coordinate systems are called
in a systems in the gradient space so
the metric Indian is trivial in general
relativity do move the complication
somewhere else to do because this
non-reality of the metric is the
curvature and that cannot be eliminated
but so in the fear blind formalism
you're saying those are orthonormal
basis vectors and then then what happens
then the I mean what would normally be I
just my curiosity then what what happens
today is that some I mean there's just a
metric is that only the metric or is
there some other object so you just
exactly just so you choose a metric
which is now one one one say or minus
one one one one
if where they mean for activity but
would you still have to keep it the
curvature somewhere else because the
curvature cannot go away by a change of
coordinates mm-hmm so so yeah so you are
using vectors that now will for example
they would have non-trivial
commutators oh that's horrifying
yeah yeah so the commutators will be
non-trivial and those with respect to
what do you mean when you do parallel
transport of one vector to another
exactly exactly they will not close if
you do the typical square of going first
one than the other one it will not slow
while here in nuclear and space did
always closest this commutator sort of
trigger mm-hmm yeah so you have you get
this epsilon with three indices which is
non-trivial and that that contains
effectively the same information as the
christopher's which came from the metric
so as I said in relativity you are
moving away you're moving then onto
reality from one place to another but
it's always there fair enough
okay well the alright good fascinating
ok I think that's ok that's it we ran
out of time um continue next time all
right
thanks all thanks to folks on the
livestream see you later